I think I'm able to give you three tips
because I've been a professional golfer
for sixty years and have traveled more
miles probably than any human being ever
and this pair of hands that hit more
balls than any man that ever lived
Golf is punting don't tell me how far
you hitting the ball so practice your
golf from a hundred yards in long drives
don't mean that much if you the best
from a hundred yards in you going to be
the winner now when you're putting learn
to keep your head still
hit the putt keep your head still don't
go moving don't be a peeping tom and
moving that head the minute you move
your head the putter goes wide and
outside the line number one number two
watch rory mcilroy the most magnificent
golf swing watch Jason Day when they hit
the ball they hit the ball and they hold
their follow-through like this after the
ball is gone good balance is important
thirdly speed I trained my body to have
speech jaar jaar at my age so you got as
a young person everyone got to have
speed and every shot requires speed and
it's the first 20 years of the toughest
good luck